i have to play this because well it's
just pretty hilarious here's our friend
our dear friend brian stelter on cnn
um talking about potatoes and other
subjects that he knows well let's let's
listen
then why was mr potato had mentioned 35
times on fox news and fox business this
week
35 times well the answer is because it's
easy
it's cheap it's really easy to do but
it's so distracting
potato head distracts from the suffering
so many people are going through
the muppets controversy distracts from
dire inequality
this stuff gets hyped up and passed
around mostly on twitter where lots of
reporters myself include spend way too
much time
and the risk is that it warps our
judgment and makes
sidebar stories seem so much more
important than they really are
and that causes even more chatter and
that's how you wind up with janine pirro
walking around cpac asking people
if you've seen hunter biden like she's a
bad meme
come to life
on friday i was about to go get dinner
for my kids when donald trump jr
attacked me in his speech at cpac
something about me looking like a gender
neutral potato head
and then the tweets started rolling in
on my computer people
telling me about donny junior insulting
me and i thought of some really cutting
responses some really clever ways to
reply
some way to go viral but then i stopped
i didn't post anything it was just
another distraction
he wanted me to respond this was just
more
bs fuel for the culture war and it does
not matter
he does he does look like a
gender-neutral potato doesn't he that's
a good line
it's a general rule here if someone has
a good line against you
don't repeat it uh because it sounds
even funnier when you repeat it
and come to think of it he does look a
lot like a gender-neutral i don't i
don't mean it as an insult
yeah it's it's simply an observation
that's all
it's not necessarily bad like a gender
neutral potatoes there's there are worse
things you could look like
um but he had but brian stelter
had a great response he had a great
comeback and and and he
he and he he could have he could have
said it
but he was too big a man for that that's
all
you know i'm too big i'm too big a man i
got the greatest i could i could take
you down right now with my wit
but um i'm i'm too mature so i'm not
going to
i could but i won't yeah sure
and of course the point he's making here
is about the potato head and the
the muppet disclaimer and all that this
is all distraction it's
a silly culture war why do you care
about this
this is one of the tried and true
tactics of the left
this is what they're always doing this
is one of their their primary strategies
it's um they make a big deal about
something
and then if we respond to it
you know they they do something make a
big deal about it
and if we object then rather than
defend what they're doing they'll say
why do you care about this
what do you care about this for so
they'll do a certain thing
throw a little a literal parade in the
street
say look everybody look at this amazing
thing we're doing
and if you stand off to the side and
simply say you know i'm not a big
fan of that actually what do you make of
such a big deal about this floor
they're up on the parade float accusing
you of making a big deal about it that's
that's the way it goes
with pretty much everything that that's
the way they fight the culture war
and that's how they often get away with
fighting it while pretending they're not
fighting it at all
all they do is fight the culture war but
then claim
that on the right all we do is fight the
culture war
and they're they're too busy and they
don't care about these issues at all
now the potato head thing was i think
everybody pretty much
everyone was simply making fun of it
it's i don't think anyone was taking
that issue very seriously
um the muppet thing though
now this is disney plus this is disney
major major corporation billions and
billions of dollars
um they've they are the ones
it wasn't we didn't do this
the disney corporation they're the ones
who decided to make a big deal out of
the muppets
such a big deal that they thought it
needed a disclaimer before you watched
a show about puppets they needed to put
this
lengthy dramatic disclaimer on it
so who's the one making a big deal about
the muppets
is is it is it is it the the group
that's putting
the disclaimer on it or is it the people
who are simply saying
that's that's ridiculous that's silly
this is the this is the strategy and
they get away with it most of the time
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends